[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
guten Abend eine Reise nach Paris ein
Mittagessen im goldglänzenden
elyseepalast ein Gespräch mit dem
engsten Verbündeten der deutschen das
ist eigentlich einer der schöneren
Termine eines Bundeskanzlers und
natürlich würde Olaf Scholz auch sagen
dass es ein sehr schönes und
konstruktives Gespräch mit Präsident
macron war hat er aber nicht gesagt weil
er überhaupt nichts gesagt hat denn es
gab nichts in Paris heute kein Wort zum
gesprächsauftakt von Kanzler und
Präsident keine Pressekonferenz danach
und so blieb die Verstimmung die sich in
den letzten Wochen über Scholz und
macron zusammengebraut hatte über dem
Treffen hängen Anna Warsberg berichtet
ein freundschaftlicher Handschlag kurzes
Lächeln in die Kameras aber außer merci
BOKU kein Wort für die Öffentlichkeit
die beiden Staatschefs verschwinden zum
arbeitsmittagessen in den elise-palast
das Verhältnis der traditionell engen
Partner Frankreich und Deutschland ist
seit Monaten angespannt und das sind die
drei Hauptgründe 1 der Umgang mit der
Energiekrise Scholz will keinen
gemeinsamen europäischen gaspreisdeckel
macron ärgert das vor allem in
Kombination mit dem doppelwumms
Deutschlands 200 Milliarden Euro
Hilfspaket zur Abfederung der Hoden
Energiekosten ein Alleingang sei das und
verschaffe Deutschland einen
Wettbewerbsvorteil in Europa die
Spannungen beruhen im wesentlichen
darauf dass Deutschland bei den
französischen Partnern den Eindruck
erweckt sich auf nationale Lösungen zu
konzentrieren beim Kampf gegen die
Energiekrise vor allem wenn es um die
Finanzierung geht und dass sie sich eher
an die osteuropäischen Länder wenden und
damit den traditionellen Partnern den
Rücken zukehren könnten als die
traditionell
ihren engen persönlichen Austausch
betonen macron und Scholz stets aber
auch der zweite große streitpunkt war
bald seit Wochen die gemeinsame
Verteidigungspolitik da läuft es nicht
gerade rund zwischen Deutschland und
Frankreich beide wollen angesichts des
Krieges in der Ukraine die europäische
Verteidigung stärken aber gemeinsame
Rüstungsprojekte wie das neuartige
Kampfflugzeug FKS Stocken und
Deutschland plant ein gemeinsames
europäisches Luftverteidigungssystem
frankreich hat andere Pläne
[Musik]
ich denke sie werden die technischen
Probleme nicht wirklich lösen können
natürlich will in so einer
Krisensituation jeder einzelne für sich
tun was am dringendsten ist aber man
kann jetzt auch klare gemeinsame
Entscheidungen treffen die zeigen dass
man weiterhin langfristig an Lösungen
für die Rüstungsproduktion interessiert
ist und dann ist er noch die Frage wie
Europa gestalten bei der Prager Rede
Ende August hat Scholz die
deutsch-französischen Rüstungsprojekte
mit keinem Wort erwähnt macron beim
botschaftertreffen schon der
französische Staatschef wünschte sich
beim ersten Treffen mit dem neuen aus
Berlin ein ähnlich enges Zusammenspiel
mit Angela Merkel ist die Tempel es ist
zu einfach zu sagen dass ist jetzt das
Ende des deutsch-französischen Paares
soweit würde ich nicht gehen die
Franzosen und die Deutschen kennen ihre
gemeinsame Verantwortung sie können auch
nicht so tun als wären sie allein in
Europa deshalb müssen sie gemeinsam an
einem Strang ziehen
sie brauchen mehr Zeit zur Abstimmung
heißt es deshalb sei der
deutsch-französische Ministerrat
verschoben worden nach dem dreistündigen
Treffen in Paris heute sollte es
eigentlich eine gemeinsame
Pressekonferenz geben aber die wurde
abgesagt und Olaf Scholz fliegt wortlos
weiter
und uns ist jetzt unsere Hauptstadt
Korrespondentin chakotala benergy
zugeschaltet schakundala erst warnt
macron Deutschland öffentlich da vor
sich zu isolieren und dann heute die
Absage der Pressekonferenz wie
schwerwiegend ist denn die Verstimmung
im deutsch-französischen Verhältnis
eigentlich also diese berühmte
deutsch-französische Achse die hat ja
auch früher hin und wieder schon mal
gewackelt auch bei Angela Merkel ist der
Elysée nicht immer zufrieden gewesen mit
ihrer Politik gegenüber Frankreich aber
beide Länder haben sich doch immer Mühe
darum gegeben in der Öffentlichkeit die
enge Freundschaft und Partnerschaft zu
zeigen und auch eben durch gemeinsame
Auftritte zu bekräftigen und das ist
schon das Bemerkenswerte an der heutigen
Reise das hier nicht einmal die Fassade
gewahrt wird und so ist es in den
vergangenen Tagen schon an mehreren
Stellen gewesen es wurden hochrangige
treffen abgesagt auf politischer Ebene
und heute eben nicht einmal eine
Pressekonferenz das ist normalerweise
ein Zeichen dass man sich für
Problemstaaten vorbehält aber nicht für
die engsten Verbündeten man muss also
feststellen dass Scholz und macron hier
zwei zwei Regierungschefs sind die bzw
ein Staatspräsident und ein
Regierungschefs sind die noch
zusammenfinden müssen und zu Hause beim
Bundeskanzler läuft es auch nicht so
ganz rund vor seiner Paris-Reise hat der
Kanzler noch schnell die chinesische
Beteiligung an einem Hamburger
Containerterminal im Kabinett
durchgedrückt ein weiteres kanzlerbaster
also in der in der Ampelkoalition wie
verärgert sind denn grüne und die FDP ja
da kann man gar nicht drumherum reden
der Ärger ist groß beide Parteien hätten
lieber es gesehen wenn die chinesische
Beteiligung dort ganz unterbunden worden
wäre sie haben dem Kompromiss nur
zugestimmt weil sie das für das
geringere Übel gehalten haben aber das
Zähneknirschen mit dem sie das getan
haben das wird jetzt schon deutlich es
gibt einen schriftlichen Vermerk vom
Grün geführten Auswärtigen Amt in dem
davor gewarnt wird dass es erhebliche
ein erhebliches Risiko gibt und dass der
Einfluss auf deutsche und europäische
infrast Natur hier unverhältnismäßig
gesteigert worden sei und dem hat sich
die FDP auch angeschlossen also beide
fühlen sich da offensichtlich nicht
richtig mitgenommen vom Kanzler und vom
Kanzleramt und werden sich jetzt in den
kommenden Wochen und Monaten genau
ansehen ob dieses Stil so bleibt denn es
gibt ja noch einige Problemfelder wo die
Koalitionspartner in schwierigen auf
schwierigen Themenfeldern zusammenfinden
müssen
Klimapolitik ist eine die Schuldenbremse
ist ein anderes Feld und das sind alles
Themen die man ursprünglich einmal in
der Ampel gemeinsam und auf Augenhöhe
diskutieren wollte da ist die Skepsis
heute mit Sicherheit gewachsen ob das in
Zukunft mit diesem Kanzler so möglich
sein wird
jakota la venergie aus unserem
Hauptstadtstudio herzlichen Dank nach
Berlin
40 Tage dauert die traditionelle
Trauerzeit im Iran eigentlich versammelt
sich die Familie des oder der
Verstorbenen an diesem Tag am Grab heute
waren es tausende die zum Friedhof der
Heimatstadt von Marsa Amini zogen die
22-Jährige Kurdin starb nach ihrer
Verhaftung in Polizeigewahrsam
festgenommen weil sie ihre Kopfbedeckung
nach Auffassung der Sittenwächter nicht
korrekt getragen hatte die Familie
selbst konnte heute nicht wie geplant am
Grab trauern Sicherheitskräfte hatten
sie offenbar gewarnt und eingeschüchtert
Jörg Brase berichtet über den
andauernden Protest gegen das
mulla-regime im Iran
es sind hunderte vielleicht tausende sie
marschieren in sarkess angeblich
Richtung Friedhof auf dem Masse Amini
begraben liegt sie tun es obwohl die
Familie aminis gebeten hatte nicht zu
kommen man werde keine Trauerfeier am
Grab abhalten um Schwierigkeiten zu
vermeiden heißt es in dieser Erklärung
sie entstand vermutlich unter Druck der
Behörden
Freiheit Freiheit rufen Studentinnen und
Studenten in der Stadt ach was ähnliche
Bilder gibt es von der medizinischen
Fakultät in Isfahan und anderen Orten
ihr seid Verbrecher schreien sie den
Sicherheitskräften entgegen die auf
einer Brücke in teheranstellung bezogen
haben im Internet kursieren heute viele
solcher Videos sie zeigen zumeist junge
Leute an den Universitäten die gegen das
Regime demonstrieren obwohl fast überall
Sicherheitskräfte zu Hunderten
aufgezogen sind für Beobachter hat das
eine neue Qualität
please days on Mini in diesen Tagen
sehen wir bei vielen Gelegenheiten das
vor allem die Frauen nicht mehr
weglaufen wenn Sie diese Uniformen der
revolutionsgarten und andere Kräfte
sehen bleiben sie furchtlos und Rennen
nicht mehr weg
an einigen Stellen im Land kommt es zur
Auseinandersetzungen mit den
Sicherheitskräften das Regime reagiert
weiter mit Peitsche und mit Zuckerbrot
gestern an der hagenazir-universität in
der Heiligenstadt kommen
Regierungssprecher Ali bahadori tachomi
spricht zu Studenten sucht den Dialog
wie er sagt doch er wird niedergebrüllt
[Musik]
wir wollen nicht mit Mördern reden rufen
einige und meinen die bisher rund 200
Toten und immer wieder Frauen Leben
Freiheit ja auch er unterstütze diese
Ziele sagt Regierungssprecher giacomi
aber er habe das Gefühl dass er hier
nicht erwünscht sei er hoffe man könne
irgendwann in einer besseren Atmosphäre
reden aber ihr schreit ja nur sagt es
und geht
[Applaus]
sie können nicht miteinander reden und
die jungen Leute an der Universität
wollen ist auch nicht für sie gibt es
nichts mehr zu besprechen
[Applaus]
hier geht es jetzt weiter mit Gundula
und den Nachrichten und dem großen Thema
Klimaschutz die Vereinten Nationen sehen
Fortschritte im Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel allerdings reichten sie bei
weitem nicht aus das Ziel den weltweiten
Temperaturanstieg auf 1,5 Grad zu
beschränken werde selbst dann nicht
erreicht wenn alle vereinbarten
klimapläne umgesetzt würden in einem
aktuellen Bericht zur Vorbereitung der
Weltklimakonferenz erklären UN-Experten
es könnte bis Ende des Jahrhunderts
sogar eher auf eine Erwärmung um 2,5
Grad hinauslaufen dringend sein weitere
Maßnahmen geboten um den CO2-Ausstoß zu
senken mit den Folgen befasst sich
gleich auch erst Intelli im
Wetterbericht
mit dem Ziel sauberer Luft will die
EU-Kommission schärfere Grenzwerte für
Feinstaub durchsetzen zunächst sollen
sie halbiert und dann laut Gesetzentwurf
bis 2050 praktisch auf Null gedrückt
werden Feinstaub gilt als größtes
Problem in Deutschland für die
Luftqualität verursacht unter anderem
durch Holzöfen Kamine und Reifenabrieb
die Folge atemwegs Herz und
Krebserkrankungen
die ukrainische Gegenoffensive im Süden
des Landes geht weiter allerdings kommt
sie nach Angaben des eigenen
Verteidigungsministeriums schlechter
voran als erhofft grund seien
regnerisches Wetter und die
Besonderheiten des Geländes in der
Region casson
währenddessen dauern die massiven
russischen Luftangriffe auf ukrainische
Infrastruktur im Süden an wie hier am
Rande der Millionenstadt nipro
vergangene Nacht wurde eine Tankstelle
getroffen nach Behördenangaben kam eine
Frau ums Leben
vor dem Hintergrund drohender Verluste
hat russlands Präsident Putin die
Behauptung wiederholt die Ukraine plane
den Einsatz einer schmutzigen Bombe eine
mit radioaktiven Material versetzten
Sprengsatz Kiew die Nato und auch
westliche Vertreter im UN-Sicherheitsrat
wiesen die Anschuldigungen erneut
nachdrücklich als falsche Behauptungen
zurück Moskau habe keine Beweise der
stellvertretende britische
UN-Botschafter verurteilte die Vorwürfe
Russlands als Desinformation
russland hat unterdessen ein Manöver
seiner strategischen nuklear
Streitkräfte begonnen erstmals seit
Beginn des Angriffs auf die Ukraine
simuliert werde ein russischer
Gegenangriff nach einem feindlichen
Atomschlag wie Verteidigungsminister
Scheu Gus sagte das Ministerium zeigte
Aufnahmen von Interkontinentalraketen
U-Booten und langstreckenbomben
Präsident Putin verfolgte die Übungen
von einem Kontrollraum aus
wir haben es gerade gehört Vladimir
Putin spielt immer wieder unverhohlen
mit der Drohung dass der Ukraine Krieg
zu einem atomaren Konflikt führen könnte
das Ziel ist klar er will den Westen
besonders die USA in Anspannung halten
der Krieg in der Ukraine hat alles
verändert auch das Verhältnis zwischen
den ehemaligen Supermächten des Kalten
Krieges die USA unter Präsident beiden
sehen sich plötzlich wieder als globale
Führungsmacht herausgefordert welche
Schlussfolgerungen Amerika daraus zieht
beschreibt Elmar thewissen
als die Sowjetunion 1962 hat Tom Raketen
auf Kuba stationierte hielt die Welt den
Atman doch die Entschlossenheit und die
klaren Ansagen der US-Regierung
verhinderten die nukleare Katastrophe
die Botschaft das solch ein Krieg keine
Sieger hinterlassen würde konnte Sowjet
Führer kuschev nicht missverstehen nur
weil Amerika hart blieb gab es in den
Jahrzehnten danach keine vergleichbare
Situation keinen Weltkrieg so meint der
Historiker timothies Schneider
wenn Sie einen Atomkrieg
unwahrscheinlicher machen wollen müssen
sie von ihm abschrecken wenn er
wahrscheinlicher werden soll müssen Sie
der nuklearen Erpressung nachgeben das
lädt die Erpresser des öfter zu tun
deshalb sprach der US-Präsident nach
Putins atomdrohungen von Armageddon
öffentlich unmissverständlich zur
Abschreckung aber wladimir Putin hat
schon erreicht was er wollte Angst vor
Breiten vor allem in und Deutschland
sind Menschen bereit ihm nachzugeben
wären sie auch bereit Schleswig-Holstein
aufzugeben oder überlasst ihm doch
Sachsen oder Mecklenburg-Vorpommern nur
um des Friedens willen jeder der so
denkt hat wirklich ein märchenhaftes
Bild von Wladimir Putin
2002 beim NATO Russland Gipfel hatte
Putin der Ukraine eigentlich ein
Versprechen gegeben damals ging es um
die Frage ob das Land Mitglied der NATO
werden könnte
die Ukraine ist ein unabhängiger
souveräner Staat der über seinen Weg
zufrieden und Sicherheit selbst
entscheidet ich sehe hier nichts
problematisches was einen Schatten auf
die Beziehungen zwischen Russland und
der Ukraine werfen könnte
trotzdem ließ Putin 2014 die Grimme
erobern und Panzer in die Ostukraine
Rollen sowie 2008 schon in Georgien und
wollte Abi
2022 ist Teil einer Kette von Kriegen
deren Ende nicht in Sicht ist wenn Putin
nicht gestoppt wird deshalb liegen im
Pentagon Pläne parat für eine massive
Antwort auf einen russischen Atomschlag
nicht nuklear sondern konventionell um
Russlands Armeen der Ukraine
kampfunfähig zu machen
es gibt nur diese eine Antwort für die
Vereinigten Staaten und die NATO um
Putin klar zu machen dass es dann keine
Einschränkungen mehr gibt bei der
Anwendung von Gewalt zu Unterstützung
der Ukraine
die Ukrainer die dem täglichen Terror
ausgesetzt sind lassen wissen dass sie
nach einem Atomschlag noch
entschlossener weiterkämpfen würden die
Nato-Partner müssen entscheiden ob sie
Ihnen dabei helfen
[Musik]
wenn Sie mehr über die weltweite
zeitenwände sehen wollen dann empfehlen
wir Ihnen die auslandsjournal Doku
Russland Ukraine und die Welt wie dieser
wie der Krieg unser Leben verändert
heute Nacht gegen 0:10 Uhr oder ab
morgen in der ZDF Mediathek
der Joint hat es heute ins Kabinett
geschafft im dortigen politiksprech
heißt die hasch-zigarette allerdings
kontrollierte Abgabe von Cannabis an
Erwachsene zu genusszwecken ja
tatsächlich die teilweise
Entkriminalisierung von Cannabis steht
im rot-gelb-grünen Koalitionsvertrag
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach
präsentierte erste Eckpunkte für ein
Gesetz hauptstoßrichtung kontrollierte
Freigabe für Erwachsene bis zu 30 Gramm
Anbau unter Auflagen dazu Aufklärung
über die Gefahren und sofort hagelt es
Kritik und jede Menge Gegenargumente am
Joint scheiden sich die Geister David
Geppert berichtet aus Berlin
es ist die wohl umstrittenste Pflanze
mit deren Blüten und Blättern im Laufe
des Lebens wohl etwa jeder Vierte in
Deutschland eine konsumerfahrung macht
unter anderem ein Arzt der gerade
Gesundheitsminister ist ich kann nur
sagen dass ich tatsächlich schon einmal
probeweise konsumiert habe das habe ich
auch öffentlich gemacht ich kann Ihnen
versichern dass ich gut genug im Stoff
bin als dass ich mich damals nicht
selbst gefährdet hätte doch wie
gefährlich ist der Stoff den die Ampel
nun in Grenzen legalisieren will für die
ein gefährliche Einstiegsdroge für
andere entspannendes Genussmittel es ist
vor allem ein jahrzehntelanges Projekt
der Grünen
unintelligible Hand frei und zwar sofort
die die Legalisierung forderten in Wort
und Bildbotschaften die damals hier
bewusst platzierte Cannabispflanze hat
die ganze Republik beschäftigt wenn ich
wollte darauf hinweisen dass die
cannabiskriminalisierung in Deutschland
ziemlich gescheitert ist ähnlich wie
einst es dem yia argumentiert Lauterbach
heute er der lange gegen die
Legalisierung war habe seine Meinung
revidieren müssen will die
Entkriminalisierung wir haben keine
wirklich also
vorzeigbaren Erfolge in den letzten
Jahren erzielen können der
Cannabiskonsum ist gestiegen Jugend und
Gesundheitsschutz sein Hauptargument das
Ärztevertreter nicht wirklich überzeugt
die einen weiter steigenden Konsum
Jugendlicher fürchten und die Folgen
Thema ist aber das Kinder- und
Jugendliche die früh konsumieren sehr
schwere Störungen davontragen können und
das muss verhindert werden bevor man
eine Legalisierung einleitet sonst wäre
das Signal natürlich möglicherweise
Quartal insbesondere an Jugendliche das
ist jetzt legalisiert also es ist völlig
harmlos Lauterbach verspricht
Jugendschutz etwa dadurch dass der
Verkauf nur in lizensierten
Fachgeschäften möglich sein soll Zutritt
ab 18 pro volljähriger Person sollen
künftig drei weibliche blühende
Cannabispflanzen angebaut werden dürfen
und Erwerb und Besitz von 20 bis 30
Gramm zum Eigenkonsum sollen straffrei
sein was der FDP nicht weit genug geht
das von Herrn Lauterbach vorgelegte
Eckpunktepapier ist nach wie vor sehr
restriktiv sehr zögerlich und gerade bei
dem besitzobergrenzen wir regeln ja auch
nicht wie viele Flaschen Bier oder Wein
jemand in seinem Keller lagert wie bei
Bier und Wein dagegen könnte der Staat
künftig an einer extra Umsatzsteuer auf
Cannabis verdienen Vertrieb und der
Anbau sollen staatlich kontrolliert
werden das bedeutet wir streben anders
also der die gesamte Menge die hier
vertrieben und auch konsumiert wird dass
sie in Deutschland produziert erklären
soll der Staat wird zum Cannabis Dealer
letztendlich für die Menschen die
Freigabe von Cannabis wird keines der
Probleme lösen und auch in den
Niederlanden ehrlicherweise ist man ja
damit letztendlich gescheitert mit dem
Ansinnen dort auch den Schwarzmarkt zu
verdrängen die geplante
cannabis-liberalisierung steht noch
unter eu-vorbehalt aus den Eckpunkten
soll erst ein Gesetzentwurf werden wenn
in Brüssel weißer Rauch aufsteigt
und hier geht es jetzt weiter mit den
Nachrichten und Gundula
so früh wie möglich und umfassend muss
die Bundesregierung bei Fragen der
europäischen Außen- und
Sicherheitspolitik den Bundestag
einbinden das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hat entschieden dass das Parlament auch
über informelle eu-beratungen informiert
werden muss um die Abgeordneten an
Entscheidungsprozessen zu beteiligen
geklagt hatten die Fraktionen von Grünen
und Linken sie waren 2015 zu spät über
die bereits beschlossene EU-Mission
Sophia gegen Schleuse im Mittelmeer
informiert worden
trotz Krieg und Krisen hat die Deutsche
Bank im dritten Quartal einen
Milliardengewinn erzielt im Vergleich
zum Vorjahreszeitraum hat das größte
deutsche Geldhaus seinen Gewinn sogar
fast versetztfacht Frank Bethmann das
Umfeld bleibt schwierig wie bewältigt
die Deutsche Bank die aktuellen Krisen
an dem sie Vorsorge trifft sie
verringerte ihre Risiken im
Russland-Geschäft und sie wappnet sich
für mögliche Kreditausfälle erhöht daher
ihre entsprechende Position in der
Bilanz kräftig trotz dieser Maßnahmen
konnte Christian sebing heute für das
dritte Quartal unterm Strich einen
Gewinn von über 1,1 Milliarden Euro
verkünden es sei das höchste Ergebnis
das seine Bank seit mehr als einem
Jahrzehnt erzielen konnte die Deutsche
Bank profitiert dabei vor allem von
steigenden Zinsen da sich Firmen und
Verbraucherkredite genauso verteuerten
wie die fürs Bauen sprudelten zuletzt
die Einnahmen gleichzeitig vergibt das
Geldhaus zwar auch wieder Zinsen für
angelegte Kundengelder die aber liegen
deutlich nicht unter denen die die Bank
für die eigene Kreditvergabe verlangt
zinsüberschüsse nennt man das die im
Übrigen nicht nur bei der Deutschen Bank
kräftig gestiegen sind insgesamt
profitieren europas Banken von der
Trendwende am Zinsmarkt und der
höhenreihen weil sie ihre
Geschäftserwartungen für das laufende
Jahr die Risiken aber bleiben Krieg
Inflation Wirtschaftseinbruch oder wie
es einen Vorstandschef einer
italienischen Großbank jetzt formulierte
für blicken mit Zuversicht in eine
ungewisse Zukunft vielen Dank Frank
Widmann
wir haben jetzt zunächst die
gewinnzahlen vom Lotto am Mittwoch sie
lauten wie immer ohne Gewähr 16 21 23 24
32 46 Superzahl 1 weitere Gewinnzahlen
auf Lotto zdf.de und im ZDF Text auf
Seite 557
am Abend ist der renommierte und mit
250.000 Euro dotierte deutsche
Zukunftspreis für Innovation und Technik
verliehen worden Bundespräsident
Steinmeier zeichnete ein Forscherteam
aus Thüringen für die Entwicklung eines
besonders schonenden
mikroskopverfahrens aus eine komplexe
wissenschaftliche Innovation zu sehen
bei der Verleihung des zukunftspreises
gleich nach dem heute journal hier im
ZDF
die Schwimmbäder machten den Anfang
extrem hoher Energiekosten wegen sind
bereits zahlreiche Hallen
deutschlandweit geschlossen die Kommunen
können die Rechnungen nicht mehr
bezahlen dann kamen die Saunen
Fußballclubs dimmen das Flutlicht und
Sportfans zwischen Kiel und Garmisch
Duschen längst schon nach dem Training
kalt alles zumutbar kann man aushalten
aber die Krise der Sportvereine geht
viel tiefer denn ein Drittel der
Sportanlagen gehört Vereinen die die
gehört Vereinen die die Energiekosten
selbst bezahlen müssen und das nur über
höhere Mitgliedsbeiträge finanzieren
können wer aber bezahlt den höheren
Beitrag für den Turnverein der Tochter
angesichtsinflation und Heizkosten über
Sportclubs am Limit berichtet Carsten
Behrendt
diese Halle ist ein Traum für die
Berliner Skaterszene und ein Albtraum
für Energieberater der Traum ist Berlins
einziger wintertauglicher Skatepark ob
für Einsteiger oder Olympia Kader der
Albtraum 1200 Quadratmetern nackter
Beton ein zugiges Dach und drei
ineffiziente heizbrenner unter der Decke
gerade hat der Gasanbieter den Abschlag
vervierfach von 1.200 auf 7000 Euro pro
Monat für die Skatehalle bedeutet es
dass wir im Grunde überfordert sind wir
haben immer mit den bisherigen
Energiepreisen gerechnet so funktioniert
gemeinnütziges Konzept jetzt wird es
richtig richtig wenn es einfach so
weitergeht wissen wir nicht was wir tun
sollen es ist noch nicht mal eine Option
einfach im Winter zuzumachen denn wenn
wir die Heizung gar nicht benutzen dann
friert sie ein und ist im nächsten Jahr
kaputt zwei Euro pro Stunde kostet das
Skaten bislang die Sorge wenn Sie die
Preise erhöhen landen sozial schwächere
Skateboarder draußen auf der Straße
überall bringen die Energiepreise
Vereinen Bedrängnis laut Deutschem
olympischen Sportbund fürchten knapp
sechs Prozent um ihre Existenz 42
Prozent sehen starke Auswirkungen in
Schulsporthallen und öffentlichen
Schwimmbädern übernehmen meist die
Kommunen die Mehrkosten für Strom und
Heizung doch manche Vereine fürchten
hallenschließungen als Sparmaßnahme
wir haben 87.000 Vereine in Deutschland
die Leisten ein wertvollen Beitrag für
den Zusammenhalt in unserer Gesellschaft
und das alles ist durch die Verteuerung
durch die Energiekrise bei den Vereinen
gefährdet besonders betroffen sind
Vereine mit eigenen Sportstätten wie die
Füchse Berlin bekannt für ihre
Profi-Handballer im Breitensport haben
sie 4000 Mitglieder bieten mehr als 25
Sportarten an wir haben zwei Jahre
Corona hinter uns also wir haben jetzt
zwei Jahre hinter uns wo der Sport
gerade im Jugend- und
Breitensportbereich doch sehr
eingeschränkte stattfinden konnte und
wir müssen schauen dass wir die Leute
weiter in den sportteilen auch in den
Tennishallen behalten können um sie auch
bei Laune zu halten und gesund zu
erhalten vor allem ihr stolz ist die
moderne Heizungsanlage für die
Tennishalle sie heizt nur wenn die
Plätze drinnen gebucht sind trotzdem
haben sie lange diskutiert ob sie sich
die Traglufthalle diesen Winter leisten
können jetzt haben sie die Platzmiete
erhöht die Temperatur auf höchstens 14
Grad begrenzt doch auch der Tonraum die
Duschen und die Geschäftsstelle
benötigen teure Energie wir rechnen mit
60 bis 80.000 Euro Mehrkosten im
kommenden Jahr das ist dramatisch das
ist dramatisch das trifft uns als Verein
auch wenn wir groß sind wirklich stark
die Sportvereine wünschen sich Hilfe von
der Politik dass die Bundesregierung wie
versprochen helfen wird den Sport unter
den energierettungsschirm stellt für die
Skatehalle ein Wettlauf gegen die Zeit
die hohen Gaskosten jetzt es droht das
Aus für das traumhafte Winterquartier
wäre das der Albtraum
das war es von uns hier geht es jetzt
also wie gerade gehört weiter mit der
Verleihung des Deutschen zukunftspreises
und heute meldet sich Hanna Zimmermann
mit unserem heute journal Update gegen
Mitternacht von uns noch einen schönen
Abend wir sind morgen wieder da tschüss
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter die 27
Weltklimakonferenz steht vor der Tür und
bisher ist beim Klimaschutz kaum etwas
erreicht worden die Konzentration von
Kohlendioxid die Ursache für die globale
Erhitzung steigt ungehindert an und
erreicht ja für Jahr neue Höchststände
kohlendioxid ist eigentlich ganz
natürlich in der Atmosphäre vorhanden
Pflanzen und Ozeane und Böden setzen CO2
frei gleichzeitig nehmen sie aber die
gleiche Menge auf ein stabiler Kreislauf
den der Mensch andauernd stört denn
durch Verbrennen von Kohle Öl und Gas
bringen wir jedes Jahr zusätzlich CO2 in
die Atmosphäre ein großer Anteil
verbleibt für viele hundert Jahre in der
Atmosphäre und lässt die Temperatur
weiter steigen deswegen ist es wichtig
so rasch wie möglich fossile
Energieträger auf Null zu reduzieren
und der ungewöhnlich warme Oktober setzt
sich weiter fort zunächst schauen wir
aber noch in die Nacht und da bildet
sich Nebel in der Südhälfte und in der
norddeutschen Tiefebene Temperaturen
gehen zurück auf 12 Grad im Rheinland
und vier Grad am Alpenrand dort ist es
am kältesten morgen nach Nebelauflösung
dann viel Sonnenschein auch nach Norden
und Osten hin ja und die Temperaturen
erreichen bis zu 24 Grad im Südwesten
und 17 Grad in der Mitte und sehr
ungewöhnlich werden die Temperaturen
Freitag bis 27 Samstag bis 26 und
Sonntag bis 24 Grad ein schöner Abend